so in the last few videos we looked at
the final version the Declaration of
Independence as it was as it was
approved of but here we look like it
seems like we have a very not final
version of the Declaration which really
amazing is they go through five drafts
at least of the Declaration and it's
wonderful to watch how each of the
drafts changes you have this committee
of real people you know Jefferson and
Adams and Franklin are all part of that
committee and Jefferson is using a lap
desk one of those little things he
invented so he could stand up or sit
down and write this in a little room on
Market Street and then he shows it to
Adams and he shows it to Franklin very
deferentially said with your broad and
view of the world dr. Franklin perhaps
you can make some suggestions I mean
certain atoms could be his father
right right Jefferson's only 33 I mean
really really young and you have you
know Franklin and Adams Franklin's and
you know Hidden 70s then ah and very
much of a father figure but you see real
people working together in these rooms
on Market Street in Philadelphia trying
to craft this document yeah yeah and you
see here me this looks like you know
someone editing a paper which shows you
how important it is to edit in a way and
this is you know those of us who are
writers and editors we like the fact
that you should you should really sort
of quibble over each word you should
make these are words that matter for
example you can see they put in a little
phrase right here separate and equal
station in other words America is going
to become a separate nation and an equal
nation but that word separate and equal
actually goes down in American history
with some resonance because it's used
for a while to defend segregation so
even when they get the you know words
almost perfect they have a resonance
that they have to be careful about and
and you think they realize when they
were writing it how important this
document was going to be one of the
amusing things is this was not
considered the most important committee
to be on in June in July of 1776 in fact
John Adams thinks he's already written a
great document of American Revolution
which is a document written in May
asking the various colonies to get rid
of their royal governors because we are
going to break away so Adams is quite
willing to let Jefferson write this
draft because he thinks that this is not
the most important of all the docket and
on some level to I guess defend Adams a
little bit that does seem like a big
deal this was in May of 1776 you rang
you know once you're getting rid of your
royal governor's you really are
separating yourself and they've already
had a vote to declare a - to be
independent so this is just a document
let facts be submitted to a candid world
you know the opinions of mankind they
should declare the causes this is really
just a public relations document but the
reason it turns out to be so important
is it so beautifully written it becomes
the American creed when they get
together in these rooms and edit it you
just suddenly they say all men are
created equal this becomes not just a
propaganda document but a mission
statement for who we are as a people and
and it doesn't really the sense that the
power of poetry I mean they could have
said these exact same things in very
terse and this is why it was so good
Jefferson wrote it because Franklin is a
very good writer but he's a very simple
plain writer you know he writes Poor
Richard's Almanack a penny saved is a
penny earned you know he's one of the
first Americans not to write in a very
flowery way John Adams as letters are
very beautiful but they kind of pompous
an aura tonton self-important you have a
beautiful poet in Jefferson but as we're
looking at this document on the screen
even he benefits from some good at it
and just I mean so this is literally
Jefferson's handwriting we see here this
is Jefferson's handwriting on the first
draft it's in the Library of Congress if
you want to go see it the final document
is in the National Archives about eight
blocks away and it's really wonderful to
look at all of these documents
especially I mean what do you see here
where they edit the the great second
paragraph so we hold these truths to be
self-evident and and you mentioned
earlier that before it was written what
sacred and undeniable yeah so so they're
using the word sake
for the truth when they when Jefferson
writes the first draft and to me if you
look at the back slashes the dark back
slashes there
those are Benjamin Franklin's back
slashes I'm pretty sure because he used
a printers pen and he was a you know
publisher and so you use that sort of
back slashes to cross things out and he
writes a words self-evident now one of
the things is we historians never fully
know Carl Becker who was a great
historian of the Declaration he's the
one who said that that was probably
Franklin's at it for me I've spent a lot
of time in Ben Franklin's papers which
were at Yale University library and to
me it really feels like his handwriting
and so we assume that it's Ben Franklin
who takes out sacred because he doesn't
want these truths to be based on
religion he wants these truths to be
based on rationality and reason and and
so once again it's not only the style of
the crossing out it's it's this is this
is in line with Franklin's personality
and beliefs
Franklin was somebody who had read the
great thinkers of the British and
Scottish enlightenment that means John
Locke David Hume David Hume was a person
who came up with the concept of
self-evident truths I mean a
self-evident truth would be that all
bachelors are married as opposed to an
as opposed to you know a more contingent
truth like Philadelphia is smaller than
London kind of in math an axiom an axiom
exactly the fact that two plus two or
two plus three is five that's not you
know that's not something that has to be
further proved and so these are somewhat
these are self-evident and that's what
Hume does and Franklin loves that and
Franklin loves Isaac Newton too because
Franklin is a scientist and so he
believes that there are laws of nature
of nature's God and that there's certain
self-evident truths so he doesn't want
the word sacred in there because that
kind of seems like Divine Right of Kings
God's the one who made these truths and
he's saying no as you as we discuss that
whole paragraph it's about rationality
and reason getting us to those truths
right but they also do talk about
as we talked about previously there's a
balance here because they did talk about
created equal let's look at tell us you
know what do you see there that you know
this edit that and you know it says that
they were you had certain inherent and
inalienable rights and you see John
Adams and I'm pretty sure we're pretty
sure that's John Adams is writing not
just because of his writing but because
of the concept he was a little bit more
religious than the others on the
committee and so he says they are
endowed by their creator he puts in that
phrase by their creator with certain
inalienable rights so to balance it's a
balance between rationality and reason
which is self-evident and divine
providence this notion that were all
children of the same creator and
therefore we're all endowed with certain
inalienable rights yeah this is really
amazing it's a realize that they were
human beings yeah that we'll human
beings will probably arguing just like
you you know Jefferson gets really upset
at some point not at Franklin and Adam
but other people start editing it and
Franklin tells him this wonderful story
about when he was a young tradesman in
Philadelphia and somebody had a sign
about selling hats and everybody tried
to edit a sign form and Franklin said
that's why I've never been on a
committee that's going to have a lot of
people editing what I write but you know
those of us who are editors we kind of
think those edits actually improve the
document yet seem like it turned out a
pretty good result you know you don't
get much better than we hold these
truths to be self-evident